welcome to screen junkies central
today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile
the uncarrier central screen jockey
screen jockey awesome I see it you guys
give yourselves a big round of applause
Joe star Hey
Oh Rob Nick how rudnick doesn't say his
own name he's too big for that everybody
say it with me 1 2 3
he'll rudnick stop it you're making me
blush ok you guys the Comic Con is
fantastic so far see a couple folks in
costume but there's one guy back there
who looks like a frightening Juggalo yes
Juggalo nation in the house magnets how
do they work you guys were hanging out
for a minute we're waiting for some of
our guests but oh in the meantime we can
just enjoy each other just drink each
other in I have a question ask it I have
a question has anyone here seen
Ghostbusters yet what do we think did we
like it anyone here that saw and didn't
care for it only one guy only one guy
you know what most people liked it so I
gotta say [ __ ] you does that mean is
that you mean I'm kidding I'm kidding I
love you whoever you are
but seriously damn what's that I think
it was Dan it was dad Dan oh good old
misogynist Dan no Ghostbusters is really
fun did you see it yeah I haven't seen
it I watched a little 8 hour movie I
like to call stranger things
Oh
has any make some noise if you watch
stranger things on Netflix make some
noise if you haven't blinked since
absolutely check it out I've only
watched the first episode but I'm like
oh I got to get back to stranger things
to talk a little bit give them uh just a
little bit of the gist
okay so straight do you you like the 80s
you like Stephen King you like an
unknown director named Steven Spielberg
do you like Dungeons & Dragons you got
eight hours to kill screen junkie
Central stranger things you know you
were going Joe you were going on such
like a roll with do you like this do you
like that do you like being asked if do
you like things yeah before I got this
job I was up for the tough sturdy Billy
at the restaurant know enough to Chili's
three got the guy that cleans the shirts
like Oh
Kaka clean my wife just told me oxy
clean your reference is incorrect
husband the oxy clean guy I think he
died that's sad gotcha oh yes
better better to die than to be shamed
like the ShamWow guy oh how the mighty
have fallen
I think that was in Julius Caesar that
exact line yes a pleasure to die then to
be shamed like the ShamWow guy the Wow
list of shams yeah that was
Shakespeare's most forgotten line John
kept the clean kitchen Shakespeare yes
he did Shakespeare kept the clean
kitchen but he didn't he didn't actually
clean his own kitchen his kitchen was
cleaned by Jacob Marsh Jacob Marley
Marley the guy from Christmas Christmas
Carol absolutely this is my slash pick
it's a smart it's the characters of
William Shakespeare and the cast of A
Christmas Carol and they get it on all
right so uh who's here at who's here in
San Diego for Comic Con for the first
time make some noise Oh who's a veteran
of Comic Con
and it's been here before oh yeah a lot
of vets in the house no effect support
your vets yeah support support your
comic-con veterans give them scenes and
ahsha's what's that they've seen some
stuff they've seen they've seen the [ __ ]
they've seen over 10,000 Deadpool's
yes okay you know what you bring up
something very important right now
thanks ok I have a question for you are
there more Deadpool's
or Harley Quinn's okay I'm gonna say I'm
gonna make I'm gonna say each one and I
think I got your answer already but
applaud for the one you think there's
more of are there more Deadpool's living
the present Weston's no questions about
this year this year this year this year
okay Deadpool's Wow damn okay Harley
Quinn's is there Harley Quinn back there
yeah yeah we just accepted our old
question whoo yeah the inception layers
upon layers levels upon levels felling
it under what what variations of
Deadpool of you guys seen you guys seen
a cat pool a dog pool we've seen an
assassin's creed pool we've seen what
SIF pulling in a pool SIF pool I saw
just coming out of the shower Deadpool
nice like Ferris Bueller was he doing
word length he was doing the the
Deadpool read and then a towel and like
something around his head what if he had
actually just been running late for the
con oh maybe maybe you got to get to
those panels you gotta get to that Hall
H line does anybody done a Hall H line
yet no boo sure is anybody gonna try to
go to the 30th anniversary of aliens
is anyone trying to go to the
anniversary of Alien Resurrection with
me the most misunderstood and misaligned
of the alien films is that the one that
David Fincher directed that no that was
uh that was alien 3 Oh alien 3 this is
the masterpiece with Winona Ryder
with Michael Wynn cut from the crow
others Sigourney Weaver yes and then she
has an alien baby oh yeah oh yeah and it
looks like slash from Ninja Turtle
secret of the use I just realized that
it's like hammer at the end it's real
okay you know what I want to ask another
question
alien or aliens okay all right I'm gonna
say each one applaud for the one you
want okay only applaud for one alien
aliens all copies of alien must be
destroyed what have you done very very
close very close both their various
votes even fight
yeah even fun so what else what else are
we looking forward to is anyone gonna
try to get into the Marvel or DC panel
no Wow give it up already
well you know what they could see
instead of the Marvel panel what's that
a little thing that you and I like to
call the tournament of nerds all right
oh well we'll talk more about that later
but come here Saturday night for the
tournament endurance it's an awesome
comedy debate show but without further
ado we're going to get this going with
the cast of con man yes you can get a
little louder than that I'm pretty sure
yes
all right let's do you want to introduce
some folks Joe they'll not let nearly
loud enough for me to do it
ladies ladies and gentlemen alan tudyk
nathan fillion PJ Haar's Moe Casper Van
Dien Mindy sterling Nolan North ladies
and gentlemen give it up for these guys
Wow so it's it's pretty great that we
have you guys here because I don't think
there's a more apropos place for you
guys to come and talk about this very
thing
so give people just a brief synopsis of
what conman is hello thank you
conman comment is a show about my
character it's about me guys it's
totally buddy it's about a character
named Rainier Lee who was on a Syfy
space show 13 years ago he flew a
spaceship and your character Jack Moore
was the captain of the spaceship and it
was canceled it sounds a lot like a
different it sounds like a different
thing but it's hard to draw from your
own experience yes but and what's where
veers off is my character ray his career
he makes a couple of bad career choices
and it just bottoms out
I will just say I want to hear more but
that's where art stops imitating life
because Allen you have one of the most
impressive IMDb's I mean from wreck-it
Ralph - frozen sits on down the list
yeah
I'm constantly being entertained by
entertainment and going oh my god
Allen's in this he never told me why
wouldn't you say something about oh yeah
I did that like it was like a couple
months ago I just Alan you do voiceover
listen to me you're with him on set all
day and you hear him like this said we
want to do this and let's go do that and
and you leave set and you go home and
you lay back on the bed and you turn the
television on you're flipping through
the channels and there's this voice
every fourth show but you know we we
Nolan North is on this panel as well
right all right over here yes mr. Lee
could say voiceover actor although so in
con man your character is Jerry Lansing
who's the second best motion capture
artist by the world the way you say it
yeah
second best what is second second second
well the first is Andy sir second is the
runner-up winner it's the first loser
first loser that's good I said runner-up
winner Nathan
same thing same thing so yeah so you
played that week we were doing a video
game together at one point right and we
remote motion capturing it while I was
writing Kahneman and I had written a
character named Nigel thrice who was the
second best motion capture artist and
and then I'm Matt Nolan and he was doing
that character in for free for free did
that free and he named him Jerry Lansing
and he was this he was like this it was
just really something to keep us
entertained while we did the Uncharted
series yeah oh yes thank you thank you
very much and
Allen was supposed to be in that and
things changed and he wasn't but it
sounds like I was fired
you were not fired he chose this will
all be questions related to this he
chose to be dismissed he dismissed
himself it was under his own power
fire me I quit no severance no one as a
mocap guy after they say in the biz
though right mocap it'sit's no perf cap
apparently gotcha do you get to wear one
of those cool suits with all the balls
on it dizzy he's wearing it down
that's true all my suits have balls so
have that after ten years well Casper
Van Dien good to see you sir so Casper
you must have a ton of experience with
cons Starship Troopers Tarzan
yeah no it's not it's not the new Tarzan
yeah one one person saw it and I don't
think they're well I heard one person
yell but yeah my Tarzan was 1998 yeah
and one person saw anything I think your
Tarzan could kick the [ __ ] out of the
new Tarzan no he's pretty tall he went
down a lot and he's got those vampire
teeth too I know but you've got the
advantage unfair advantage did you get
the job I do
yeah I do have the job captain ja yeah
it's a mocap ja strive for that only I
didn't want to get in there I want to be
the third best loser next to the first
second top loser second winner winner
winner winner I'd quit
so you choose to quit I chose that so
I'd love to just so since everybody has
so much comic-con experience I'd love to
just throw this out there what's a story
that was just truth is stranger than
fiction moment where you were like wow
we got to put this in the show in the
webseries con man well one of them in
season 1 dreaming now and comic-con HQ
is I was at a con in Florida and I was
waiting in line to check in line was
long and as I was standing in the lobby
I was looking at all these women who all
had babies they all had these they all
had but they were there holding babies
or they had baby carriages and they were
all in their 50s and it was a little odd
and then a woman walked up with a baby
that was this big it was a doll and then
I realized oh my god these are all dolls
this is a doll convention and it was one
half of the hotel was a doll convention
and the other half of the hotel was a
sci-fi convention and that's what I was
there for and they were there for theirs
and so we did that in the first season
and Tricia Helfer from Battlestar
Galactica
she plays our doll lady she plays she
becomes my romantic interest in in that
three in that episode so that was very
convenient that Tricia Helfer was your
love interest because you should be
noted that Ellen writes it too and casts
it Mindy sterling was my love interest
in season one and that's why she's not
here Mindy sterling is amazing she's in
her sixties but she's amazing
she was amazing she they're not sixties
precludes anyway let's move on from that
you know what we actually have a clip of
the show let's go ahead yeah and take a
look at conman
in the fall of 2004 a television network
foolishly canceled the epic space show
spectrum
but fans kept spectrum alive in their
imaginations and safe in their shattered
hearts now 10 years later an army of
fans celebrate the caste and conventions
are devoted to the adventure and the
mythos that was and always will be
spectrum everyone loved spectrum well
everyone but raid nearly it was a great
show it was the best thing I've ever
done that's the problem science fiction
is supposed to be about the future now
why are the fans so obsessed with the
past are you nearly famous I have an
audition could you maybe put in a good
word for me all famous people don't know
all other famous people Wray but yeah I
know it said that it was written for a
30-year old no I complete 30 right we're
gonna switch this up a little bit
instead of reading razor burn would you
please read the role of Marion Marion
I'm allergic to nuts I don't I want to
quit this I need you to take your seat
please
okay excuse me you wouldn't happen to be
a sci-fi fan with luck off
she's so like a darts world
oh he's sexy come see the freak of
nature the oddity mr. Cho tell me for
Kate what happened to my tennis for his
pants maybe it should be merchants of
Venus oh of course you said you were
with the convention there's a doll
convention in the wrong hotel she looks
just like that hot hot Cylon no the
other one the other one the other one
the other one that's a dude I'm married
yeah that that ain't right I got
something better for us to do what a
movie you want you want me in one of
your movies I'm making a movie with Jack
Moore and we are you son of a are you
doing a special movie no there's no
spectrum movie we're gonna make this
movie I'll do the movie under one
condition
no crowdfunding when people say that
you've been pigeon holed it doesn't mean
you're stuffed until hold it the pigeon
lives it is a hole in the pigeon yeah
Wow
that was all season one their resident
that's amazing not only was it a funny
moment after funny moment but there's so
many awesome familiar faces in there
Henry Rollins Felicia Day yeah you must
call it like I want your rolodex there's
a lot of good people in there yeah yeah
yes there are there are a lot of great
people in there I was I was amazed I was
shocked
those were them a lot it was a good it
was a yeah it was a good script I wrote
it Thank You PJ you should have yeah I
mean does that a lot of that come from
the relationships that you've made you
pick up the phone and they say yes or
what's up yeah I pick up the phone and
they say we'll get back to you and then
I call Nathan I pick up the phone I'll
call Nathan in the Nathan makes a call
I'm on it yeah honestly when we were
coming up with this idea I thought we'd
be kind of pulling in favors from
friends maybe that time I let you my
bike you gave it back to me it was all
dirty but I didn't say anything I
thought we're gonna have to like beg
people to do this thing but we were
running out of parts so fast that the
only way to keep more of our friends in
it was to do a second season
Wow and there's a really cool story
behind this
Joe coming together you had a huge
IndieGoGo campaign and the crowdfunding
the crowdsourcing for this project off
the charts tell me about putting that up
and then the response we we're we
originally work on a crowd fund you know
we tried to go to the traditional route
and we went to the studios and that and
they didn't really get what we were
doing
and we decided let's talk to the fans
and crowd fund it and we were a little
hesitant in the beginning would the fans
back it and then they backed it to the
extent where we still hold the record
for the highest crowd funded web bill
awaited of all time off the charts tell
me about putting that as we have
crowdfunding we got some people out in
the crowd with some questions for the
panel and I think we've got some good
ones gentlemen if you're ready this is
Marc Marc how you doing sir
pretty good how about you guys excellent
awesome all right so you guys see lots
of people tons of fans and all the cons
you're very recognizable folks I was
just curious what is the weirdest thing
that has ever been said or done to you
by a fan we all look at Casper Casper
what stays in the screen junkies office
stays in the screen junkies office
definitely screen junkies office
weirdest thing that ever happened to me
by a fan well it's similar it's not as
bad as the toilet one here that I was
taking uh I was in bathroom
anas leaking and the guy goes - you're
so awesome in Starship Troopers and I
said no the guy goes you're so awesome
in starship trooper I go I'm not
fist-bumping you either and then they
put that in this and I was like they had
the better one though because underneath
there I would have been like I know
Nathan yes he didn't want to shake his
hand like that was give it up for Marc
you guys
and I'll just follow up you guys shot
and an actual con isn't that right no I
mean we shot background footage at
Megacon phoenix con the one that went
the enemy one in atlanta but all the
cons in our shows we built them Wow
impressive
in this season we built the Chaka Khan
which is the biggest carnival lead with
its own obstacle course of swinging
blades what are they called the blades
of it kills people they have to close it
down because it's sending everybody to
the hospital and nobody's made it to the
end of the obstacle course with their
lives yeah tune in tomorrow tomorrow in
Hall H 10:30 we have the premiere of
season 2 the trailer if you want to come
be there for that let's get another
question from the crowd guys I'm down
here with Andre Andre what you got so
you all got a lot of movies on your
background but which was the grossest
scene that you ever had to senior
brother film I had to get in I did a
movie called slither which is a very
slimy movie if you can imagine a lot of
KY jelly KY jelly and blood fake blood
mixed together I saw this with yeah
coupled together with here's something I
didn't realize coupled together with
freezing weather at northern Vancouver
area
I had like blood and slime and KY on my
face and they had to keep wetting it and
wetting it and wetting it because it was
freezing it would freeze well guess what
happens to your skin if something
freezes on it he had this damage gonna
chapped gross it really that was gross
it was the chapped face after the KY
I can honestly say an expression I have
not heard before the chapter KY Alan
you've such a huge body of work what's
like one experience that's like stands
out
oh the working conditions or getting
covered in something or I don't I don't
like the minute a job is over it wipes
it away sure it's over it's completely
over right there's actually a there's a
phenomenon note you know in you what you
go oh I'm gonna get my something from
the other room and you walk into the
room and go what did I come in here for
yeah okay that's a thing it actually
happens your brain does a reset when you
enter a room when you cross the
threshold reset that's what happens
after a job like people say hey what was
your favorite an episode of castle I did
eight years of a show I can't remember
the last show I did
I got no idea buddy the one where we
solved that murder and it was funny that
was my favorite too okay so um on that
you saying that okay projects you forget
about them I be remiss if I didn't ask
you guys about Firefly just one of the
below the most beloved space shows nerd
culture shows of all time you talked to
me a little bit about the untimely death
of Firefly how it influenced this show
conman and yeah I think just people just
wanna hear you talk Firefly
well I can talk about how it influenced
I mean for I mean Firefly was the best
and wish it should have gone on and on
and that's why I people like it because
when you watch it you go oh this it just
doesn't yeah you just want more and for
me I got introduced to cons from Firefly
it was after that you invited me you're
like we got to introduce me to that guy
skeevy guy but we didn't know that at
the time and we went I went to my first
con and with you in London I had no idea
what I was and I've been going to him
ever since cons are a lot of fun men I
mean I mean you guys have fun of cons
right it's like that only it's up here
and it's super duper fun but when we're
together it's even more fun so we like
to do these things together I love going
to cons I'm going one alone no problem
but if I can go to one with my buddies
I'm totally in Nolan I want you to
answer this question as me what do you
miss most about Firefly
speak of the slither Firefly what the
hell's Firefly I meant guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 I was totally talking
slithers [ __ ] don't listen to him this
is about to turn into the guardians of
the galaxy to panel okay but you were
going to my depression of Nathan I don't
have an impression of Nathan but if I
did he'd be charming as hell now you
know I actually I actually have a Nathan
Fillion story that he doesn't know I
actually I read against Ryan Reynolds
for two guys a girl in a pizza place I
didn't get it if you didn't know but
then they liked me so they brought me
back to play trailer Howard's boyfriend
and I didn't get it because he got and I
remember going to our major I said I
can't nail that thing and he said this
guy Nathan Fillion I said who they said
need the Billy was in Firefly and I went
to guys was before Firefly right but if
you told that story to your agent after
Firefly say who did I lose it to then it
would have medicine yeah because I was
too drunk the day I realized it but ya
know I Michael Rooker everybody and just
before we move on from Firefly any any
Joss Whedon stories or thoughts that's a
clever guy Joss Whedon is a clever guy
and he runs a tight ship I really enjoy
being on
on a joss whedon project and I worked
before Firefly and I got to Firefly go
oh this is what it's about
this is what it's supposed to be like
this is what's like and I I haven't had
such a I wasn't so invested in
experience like Firefly until conman and
I think Alan runs a very similar ship to
jaws but just not as smart that's fair
josh is pretty smart guy but you're
artsy I'm Martin and I and I have to say
I'm a I am a Kosho runner with PJ Haar's
ma he handles the hard stuff and and I'm
talking like bourbon scotch it's the
hard stuff well you compare me to Joss
Whedon and not just the way we throw
that's amazing your ginger geniuses yep
yeah it's insane how he'll write act
produced direct everything while doing
Star Wars powerless Disney all that's
going on the same time and it will be
talking somebody he'll do this it's a
minor stroke oh what'd you say little
blank out he'll no ill have just
rewritten three pages he'll change where
the cameras gonna go he's changed the
set piece and everybody just goes okay
sure let's do that
he also on conman season 2 i brought my
my girlfriend to my two daughters and
then all of a sudden he comes over he's
busy he's doing everything and then he
starts doing every voice from every
cartoon that that isn't in existence and
they're like they're just sitting there
like like how does he do
all those voices and they come out of
one person dad and I go and then I do
the same face
what did you say he's amazing he's so
sweet with kids absolutely
PJ mentioned Star Wars Alan you are in
rogue one correct what when were you
gonna tell me Alan I do us a favor tell
us everything yeah you know or something
yeah if it comes out in December
it's called Star Wars I'm a droid I play
k2s oh I'm seven foot one and black and
which typecasting typecasting finally I
get to play what do they call you for
short my outside huh what do they call
you for short key to us s1 get to us o
k2 s o diego luna's k he calls me K - K
- K Joe he's great he's ke
Diego's character is my owner he
reprogrammed me I was an imperial droid
and he reprogrammed me and when he was
well no that's that's that was that was
said he reprogrammed me and when he
reprogrammed me alright he's a little a
little bit off one all the time but at
times he's he's kind of sassy well you
are very sassy I think we have five
sassy gentlemen up here I want to thank
Oh before we go there one thing that we
wanted to say is what we have coming out
next month there are no con man the game
August 24th build your own con yeah for
your mobile devices it's very cool we
have a clip
all right we don't have a clicker we
love it up here here and probably at our
if if you're at the hall H tomorrow guys
I'm playing it now it's awesome playing
Pokemon the best
it's like Pokemon go with alan tudyk and
you gotta pull down allen's pants he's
so embarrassed
it's great we have waited testing right
now in australia but uh it's about to
come out
ah it's all ready to go pretty much so
it's con man the game I'm in the game
come in the game download it on your
mobile device Alan Tudyk
Nathan Fillion PJ Haar's ma
thank you gentlemen conman check it out
on video guys keep it going
screen junkies central keep it going
Casper Van Dien best hugger in the
business guys we're going to keep this
going
make some noise from honest GameTrailers
met Rob and the head writer of honest
trailers from screen junkies Spencer
Jake Gilbert ladies and gentlemen Matt
and Spencer Spencer Matt and Spencer
Matt and Spencer Matt and Spencer Matt
and Spencer Matt and Spencer oh boy can
we quit him on it's always been it's
always been a dream of mine to quack
someone onto stage like for mati ducks
can we can we quit can we quack screen
junkies central quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
ladies and gentlemen Robert Spencer Jake
Gilbert screech oh dude whoo ducks fly
together man thank you
hey guys what's going on you want to sit
over there and I'll sit over here we'll
sandwich him that'll be fun we're gonna
sandwich him it's gonna be wonderful
Spencer you are the best no you guys are
the best
you guys are the best you guys having a
good time that was an amazing panel
wasn't it wasn't that awesome we have an
equally amazing panel if not better
mostly just because we're gonna be up
here we're gonna be asking awesome
questions who the hell my great question
guy in the middle row
I'm Matt Robin the new host of gamer
fights on screen junkies Plus also host
of honest game trailer commentaries hgtc
50 food where we talk about a show that
I exact produced over at Smosh games and
now on screen junkies plus honest game
trailers which is awesome one guy loves
it dude dude it's Dave Chappelle the do
you guys play video games okay who
doesn't do you guys play pokemon go
there's a gym two blocks out no I'm just
kidding we'll stay here we'll stay right
here where my Fowler's dad I just want
to know yeah right here all right good
good yeah I got one guy up there he's
the VIP it's all that matters so we have
an amazing panel we're talking about a
awesome new series called
unlocks which is talk about all things
about videogames and you don't
necessarily need to be a fan or
inundated in the video game world in
order to think this stuff is really
interesting we have some awesome guests
we're gonna have come out here and talk
about video games in general unlock the
series I think we have something we can
run but I think we're going to show you
guys that a little later
let's get to our guest it's awesome
Nathan Fillion is humping one of them
backstage right yeah we hopefully
they've done over him because they were
making sweet passionate love all right
they're ready to go they're ready to go
all right I guess first and foremost she
is all over the place you've seen her in
a million different things out of the
world you see her over at comic-con HQ
you're gonna see her right on the stage
it's out in Haslett Wow where to even
begin with this guy he likes big guns he
likes killing zombies he likes being an
all-around badass fast cars fast cars
welcome to the stage Michael
[ __ ] hooker
give it up for the man that's a bottle
cap Artie already causing trail join and
then of course the director and
executive producer of unlocked we got
welcome Jeremy Sneed and Brett Womble
yeah no we will not share all right guys
who designed this table I did why it's
too wide cuts off there I can't see the
hole I can't see their feet Michael
Rooker Bigfoot guy alright so I want to
know what is unlocked tell me tell me
guys look I don't know what there's a
fish yes what is it locks it's delicious
album with bagels and cream cheese
unlocked is a eight part documentary
series on the simplest way to say it is
the past present and future of gaming so
video games the movie which I directed
about two years ago came out and is a 90
minute kind of high level look at the at
the gaming industry and I met Brett who
then helped to orchestrate unlocked and
the idea being gaming is something that
that the Vox Populi looks at with a lot
of cliches of like oh the violence
debate or you know kids sitting in their
parents basements playing games and
that's something that we wanted to to
address and say hey there's there's so
many different areas of gaming that
people don't know about when we can make
a doctor but what better way to do it
then to bring celebrities Tom Arnold and
Sean Astin
to tell the story so the familiar faces
faces that you're seeing the story
through that's that's the hope that
makes sense I get it I totally so
serious sound very cerebral sorry no I
liked it me I liked it you likes it now
I mean we're all talking video games
obviously the two of you are fans of
video games as a culture as video games
as actual entertainment pieces
Michael Allison once you talk about your
involvement and video games obviously
motion captures something that you
talked a lot about in this series
Michael once you tell me what's your
favorite video game man yeah cuz on on
the spot is it anyone you're in I get
dizzy when I play these games I like
lollipops a choice in fact directed by
James Gunn some knowledge on y'all black
ops 2 black ops 2 I like it I like it
Allison yes my favorite game yeah right
now ah okay this is tough adult Allison
her favorite game is portal and portal 2
fair those are like my ideals like
puzzle solving all I want to do is solve
puzzles but it's puzzle solving with a
storyline uncharted the Uncharted series
would take a very close second to that
but like overall like my love for video
games that overall game has got to be
Mario Kart cuz like that's the game like
I'll still go back to Mario Kart you
know I'll still also play Yoshi any day
any day is that the one that where they
go in those little cars little cars yes
little cards the Italian plumber and the
other Italian plumber and the little
dinosaur yeah yeah yeah but they're
called marry Mario Kart yeah yeah I
don't like it either Michael we share
our position well I want these guys to
really understand what these guys to get
what we're talking about I think we
promo of unlocked we could roll I want
you guys to be able to see this that
when we talk about he kind of understand
you're able to put some visuals to it so
I guess let's let's roll it huh in just
three days the video game Grand Theft
Auto 5 is full day more than 1 billion
dollars of sales violent video games
have encouraged the killing of innocent
people some of those games can actually
help children in their thinking and
focus
video games are a cultural experience it
all has to do with not so much of the
technology but how the games are
experienced and remembered by the people
who are playing them I do I think it
took I think that over the course of
this thirty years I look at it now and I
say hey you know maybe Mario is kind of
up there with Mickey Mouse I absolutely
believe that Mario and Mickey Mouse are
right the same level
the big fear I think what people started
gave me a lot was oh that's going to
take these kids and isolate these people
no they're actually social with people
around the world
as it turns out video games actually are
one of the most effective pain
management tools that we have here at
the hospital
playing a lot of violent video games
leads to an increase in these aggressive
thought patterns is there evidence to
support that violent thought patterns
translate into violent behavior we're
not able to find evidence that that type
of associative thoughts are predictive
of future behavior you're saying the
verdicts out
the goal in virtual reality is to
represent the virtual cameras exactly as
your eyes would be in the real world
this is the first time I've understood
who could have anticipated where games
have come it was technology when the
things 8 other little things but now oh
what an art form as a nap during in a
game when I get deeper into the
character it becomes more natural and
more real and then shows and you believe
it as you're playing the game Madison
Square Garden sold out because of video
games we've grown to over 67 million
players every single month science has
proven video games are good for
cognitive abilities you know it just
teaches you how to problem-solve
look at that that was me whoa I talk you
talk to your old you shot stuff it's
such a all-encompassing documentary I
watched the first six episodes and you
cover so much stuff how games are made
how you do performance capture the
psychology games did you draw the line
there are six episodes did you did you
get to the point of like sonic erotic
fan fiction area like we can't include
that that's too much is there anything
you left out of this because it's so
comprehensive use your own imagination
well it's interesting because you know
as any gamer knows Brett and I talked
about this that there's if you were to
sit down and say we want to make a
series about gaming the the the subject
matter is endless I mean virtual reality
games used as rehabilitation in
hospitals which we did with Zelda motion
capture we do with Rooker you can make a
whole show on Pokemon go right now we
could yeah and which is something's left
out and Alison did Nintendo she cut we
covered a whole thing with Alison a
Nintendo I meant like Nintendo legacy
that day and Nintendo puppets and the
dough puppets right yeah that was that
was really cool just like as you know I
grew up playing Nintendo and then like
meeting the guys who literally released
the very first Nintendo Entertainment
System they're like you know we've
worked at the company for 30 odd years
and I'm like I I might what my career I
have a career because you guys did that
you know yeah it's the whole reason I
ever got a job at g4 was cuz I played
video games all through school what's
interesting because they pay you well
well g4 doesn't exist anymore sadly they
don't but these I get now pay me well
well it's interesting because no matter
what topic we were on whether it was
Nintendo or motion capture with this guy
there were always revelations you know
the host that the goal of the show is
that the hosts would come in and learn
think about the subject matter whether
it was Nintendo or motion capture or you
know kids in hospitals with Zelda and
every single time like we prepped you
with the questions of like hey we're
going to be talking about motion capture
and performance capture and facial
scanning and then you went in and
learned things that we didn't even have
on on the schedule like you know you
know when they put you in that room with
all the cameras around you and you were
asking questions that we didn't even
have planned so what you see in a
documentary is someone who's actually
learning legitimately even though we
tried to plan out like ask these
questions and the same was true with
Allison and all of our hosts so it's
it's it's sort of this trip a lot of fun
actually I I would learn it in the next
day I'd forget it already so I'd have to
relearn it again so it's kind of fun
watch the the coolest thing I learned
which I think made it into the
documentary and I think of this at it
but I'll tell you guys here now is that
the entire reason mario cuz we did this
at e3 last year when I was the 30th
anniversary of Mario the reason he has a
mustache is solely so you could define
his nose from the rest of his face and
the sole reason he's wearing overalls is
so you could define his arms from the
rest of his body but like a mustache
overall wearing man is like the icon of
all video games now and it was literally
done just to make it clearer on the
screen there was no like backstory there
was no like yes what we need is an
Italian plumber who takes down gorillas
or something like that then we just
looked better on the screen and we've
now so they say
ecology around this character which that
blew my mind when I found that out or
like that you know Rooker
how performance capture with with actors
it's something where like when you were
in the in black ops 2 you were in the
jet and what you see in the game is you
know first-person hands-on a controller
and the cockpit but then what actually
you were like sitting on a box or
something holding like a banana or I
don't know you told the story alright
well I'm sitting in a box and I'm
holding like they I'm just holding it
like a stick in my hand and I'm using it
like it's a jet you know a fighter plane
jet I
I flew and I did a little movie once
so the the f16 they're very you know
you're not doing like this it's just
very very slight movements and you're
like doing a 180 so it's not a big how
that comes you know and how that comes
through in the performance and how
you're playing these games like Call of
Duty and stuff and you take for granted
the motion capture which is sort of we
all we all know and we've seen avatar
we've seen the behind the scenes of
Avatar of how it works you know
photogrammetry and and performance
capture but you're the stories that you
told Anderson captures like basic though
really it again it gets you back to
acting basic acting what like this is a
knife you know but it's a pair glasses
you know but if you use it like it's a
knife the motion capture guys can make
it look like a knife right because they
added in later on but Michael is it
harder for you and instead of looking at
Norman Reedus you're looking at a
cardboard box you know it's it harder
for you to get in character and stay
committed what do you mean by that
when you know aspersions on norm reeves
acting fine actor fine man but like
you're in a unitard covered in ping-pong
balls like does that make your job
harder No
Oh respect yeah no no no no you mean for
what like The Walking Dead
yeah as compared to acting on film and
television is performance capture is
that tougher for you no no no it's you
it's actually very refreshing because
you get to use your imagination even
more working on a show like The Walking
Dead dude you get a real ar-15 yeah you
got a real knife okay those are real
ticks you're pulling off your belly all
right so it's the real deal and you and
you you get hurt you sweat you bleed
it's real so it's not Act motion keep
watching Dead's a documentary motion cat
motion capture is completely opposite I
mean it's it's like okay we have some
tape and this is your set if you I mean
if you step a foot out of the line
you're you're off you're no longer in
the game you know that's it and
everything you use everything you pick
up is whatever they kind of make it it
could be a bloody bazooka you know and
it's really honestly only a piece of
wood a lot of fun a lot of fun I just
want to say Merle should have never died
in walking bag look at you you're biased
my executive producer Bret Womble
everyone give him a hand yeah I just
like probably the only thing you all
find interesting from my perspective is
I was 28 doing sales and I've always
wanted to get into film but didn't go to
film school didn't do any of that and
basically Jeremy and I didn't even know
each other but when in LA or when video
games came out I reached out to him and
said I want to get into this and we flew
him down to Lubbock Texas which is not
the film capital of the world by any
means and we got the whole thing funded
and I just had somebody apologize to me
a second ago because they were like oh
the green rooms over there I'm so sorry
at you I didn't know you're on the panel
and that's never happened to me before
I've arrived
well but also I mean I just on a serious
note you know coming from an independent
background you know video games the
movie was was a Kickstarter that the
gamer community probably most of you
guys funded and that was a passion
project of mine I didn't know that is
that why I didn't get paid very much
that's right for for video games but
what would you people give more for
God's sake I didn't get paid for video
games the movie did you get paid for
this yeah you did did you okay okay you
know what
women do get paid more than men so yeah
you it was so awesome you guys to take
these relative Outsiders to the game
industry I know you're you've been there
for life but to show like Tom Arnold and
Penn Jillette and Sam from one of the
Rings Sun Astin Rudy and teach them and
teach them all about this my question is
how do i trick my girlfriend now wife
into liking video games have her watch
on logged there you go guys you got to
watch unlocked and we tell these people
how they can find it right now if you go
to unlock TV show calm that has all the
information about the show we're still
in negotiations with networks
fingers crossed it'll come out this fall
eight part docu-series on gaming and it
really is I mean in all seriousness it
is something that that I and Brent set
out to to to do something that with guys
like Rooker and Haislip and Tom Arnold
and Sean familiar faces not just telling
the story because that's something
that's sort of like this 90s Nickelodeon
of like there's a host of a show and I
think there's a disconnect with our
generation where it's like oh there's a
host so I know it's not real I know this
host is being told what to say and what
to do and really are what we did with
unlocked was to say hey here's the
subject matter whether it's motion
capture or a Nintendo or Sean Ashton
with game design schools or Tom Arnold
at you know talking to you know the
pioneers of the industry to really let
them learn and so that the audience
learns by proxy through through familiar
faces so that's the idea whether we you
know got across the finish line of
mission accomplished will be you know up
to you guys the audience well its
workers gotta eat guys
remember if you will be accepting
donations afterwards guys thank you so
much for doing the panel unlock TV show
comm you guys gotta check it out I want
to give a big big round of applause for
ok ok really really I cannot leave a
panel ever okay without telling us who
Starling status without a Q&A of some
sort we get we get one question one all
right guys
oh he's the boss who wants to ask the
question go ahead raise your hand
yes go ahead what's your question yell
it out what may be a favorite moment
from unlocked shooting unlocked my
favorite moment yeah lunch time we had
good lunches yeah what's your favorite
moment I met Miyamoto I met the dude who
created our childhood and not just met
him sat down with him for like a 30
minute conversation which was
interesting because he doesn't really
speak that much English so he has a
translator but he's still like the most
genuine human being I've talked to and
he he's just so happy to be doing what
he does 30 40 years later he loves that
that he has created these characters
that are so iconic to us and that he
still is trying to
to evolve them and all that he was I was
done I sat down with him and I'm like
hey oh my god that was dad sir do you
have a favorite moment favorite moment
of unlocked was writing a check to this
guy yeah and how about you sir do you
have a favorite moment my favorite was
wiring the money so that Jeremy could
ride there you go damnit where did it
all go it's behind the fridge thank you
guys very much and for those you guys
were watching it off this has been an
amazing day and we're not done we were
going all throughout the week lots of
awesome panels some amazing stuff
happening so I tuned in and I hey happy
Comicon guys it's great thanks again to
sponsor t-mobile with double the LTE
coverage get your screen junkies fix and
more places to watch our previous show
click to the left and to view everything
else from screen junkie central click to
the right
you